[Music]
for some in walker short it was a near
miss a brush with death this young girl
dressed in pink is safe but only by
inches many were not so fortunate
this is the moment families watching the
christmas parade realize something is
horrifically wrong a red suv speeds past
a marching band off camera it plows
indiscriminately into other performers
mowing them down from behind
school children and dancing granny stood
no chance many parade-goers were injured
it was just absolute chaos people
screaming and i immediately ran
downstairs outside of my apartment and i
could see kids
just laying on the street people putting
blankets over them trying to attend to
them kids screaming on the sidewalks and
not really knowing what happened
after i got closer to the scene i saw
many people on the floor
that was the moment i stopped filming
because i was really impacted by seeing
all the people there bleeding and
screaming in terror a lot of people were
injured and were being assessed on the
floor unfortunately a lot of children
were involved in this act
the car had cleared a police cordon
officers shot at the driver attempting
to stop the carnage
today we experienced a horrible
senseless tragedy
i walked in the parade at the beginning
i saw the happy children
sitting on the curb i saw the happy
parents behind their children
i can still see the smiling faces
a parade is a celebration for our
community
today our community faced horror and
tragedy in what should have been a
community celebration
we're no longer looking for a suspect
vehicle
we do have a person of interest in
custody at the moment but this is still
a very fluid investigation
as president at this tragic event and
saw firsthand the resiliency
of the community coming together
schools across walkershore are closed
today this city of 75 000 is coming to
terms with the death and destruction
visited upon it questions now turn to
who this is at the wheel and why they
turned a joyous celebration into a
nightmare martha kellner sky news